the story  everybody wants a happy ending he does  miss you and you're not here but it  doesn't always roll that way  maybe this time  i'm hoping if you play this back  it's in celebration  i hope  families are reunited i hope we  get it back and something like a normal  version of the planet has been restored  [Music]  and for better or worse  that's the reality morgan's gonna have  to find a way to grow up  i need everything to stop  i'm really sorry that i dragged you  i wanted to earn the board  this is our chance  i love you three thousand  need it to stop  [Applause]  there will be no survivor  you are lying to yourself  hope  which is the only thing  stronger than fear  [Music]  and again that's the hero gig  part of the journey  contain it  i love you 3 000.  if you need me  i'll be there